what I'd like to talk about is the idea
of joy and I'm not talking about the
idea of playing a game with with with
your one of your kids or but more the
joy that you get when you write the
perfect function when you when you find
the perfect abstraction when you like
going to work in the morning when you
have this energy that drives you to be
more productive that's the joy that I'm
talking about you might call it a
personal passion but one of the things
that I'd like to do is talk about this
topic in in a shared language so we'd
like books and we like programming
languages so I'd like to kind of use
that as like the cornerstones as we go
through this topic together so back in
the day
nice job is sudden to set me up here to
rush back in the day I wrote this book
called bitter Java at the time I was a
Java developer and I was only a Java
developer so how many of you at some
time in your career have said there's
really no difference between programming
languages it's all about the community
yeah so that's so there are other people
out there that would be racing their
hands too they say oh yeah my my brother
had that idea once right but it's it's
it's the very much the view that I had
and at some point at some point I found
myself at IBM then I saw all my friends
leave IBM to join startups and I saw
them become millionaires and then I said
oh I want to leave IBM and become a
millionaire so I joined a startup called
I can it's called what was it called it
was called all my stuff and it was a
horrible idea
and it was right before the internet
bubble burst and I went down with that
startup and I thought I'll go back to
IBM and they said no you can't go back
to IBM so I said I can write a book
right so
I wrote this book and I think it's a
terrible book with a great title
and if you look at the reviews you'll
see that they say it's a terrible book
with a great title but this book was put
out before the internet was really
popular before Amazon was was putting
books out and one of the things that
happened was that people started talking
about why bitter Java was written right
they started talking about oh this this
book is about about sticking it to the
man this this book is about saying oh
this Java the evil empire and it wasn't
about that at all as an arrest said it
was about people making mistakes in in
Java and how to avoid them but the other
interesting thing about this book is
that for one hour this book was number
eight on Amazon between Hawking's and
John Grisham I mean from one hour right
and then it kind of fell and he kept
falling and it kept falling too you know
probably it's its all-time low right now
but at some point I I was actually
broken out of the of this funk by a guy
named Dave Thomas and it's okay you can
applaud I love Dave - yeah so Dave is a
very good friend of mine is actually a
mentor and he gave this this advice in
in a in a book called the pragmatic
programmer and he didn't give this
advice to me in quite this way you see I
I caught Dave who is the consummate
British gentleman at a at a low moment
he had been giving talks all day and we
were on a train we were on speaking to
her and we were on a train going back to
the airport and I kept asking him about
Ruby but in a pretty aggressive way
because I wasn't interested but I was a
little bit afraid and it was coming out
is like youthful arrogance and so I kept
saying Shirley Shirley Ruby can't do
this the way Java does Shirley it's not
it surely it's not fast enough
and finally the concert
meant British gentleman Dave Thomas said
Bruce shut up
do something non-trivial in Ruby and
then we can have a conversation and I
did and it changed my career so actually
it changed my career more quickly than
I'm will then then I would ever be
willing to admit probably four months
after that conversation this book came
out and I went to this this symposium
called the server-side symposium does
anybody remember the server-side
yeah so this was a hot site for for
discussing Java server-side programming
and I was on this I was featured on the
side a lot because I used to write
editorials I used to do commentaries and
things like that and the reason was that
one of my one of my good friends was ed
Roman and he was one of the founders of
the server side and he was he was
helping me get started well I was at the
server-side symposium which was a
conference in Europe and this reporter
wanted to ask me about this book so this
book was really about saying hey pick
your eyes up your java career is not
going to last forever you know I guess
this was like 15 years ago now so maybe
that wasn't good advice right but but
the idea was to pick your eyes up
something else is coming and you need to
be paying attention or or your career
could be in some peril and so the
reporter asked me a question kind of a
gotcha question he said so
Bruce you think Java is dead right and I
said no no no nothing could be further
from the truth
we'll always be using Java just like
we're always using cobalt right now so
what I mean is dead like COBOL not like
Elvis right and so the next day on the
on the front page of the server-side
there's this big old quote
CAPITAL LETTERS right brew state says
java dead like COBOL right and so I
needed out from Java to Ruby right so I
needed to establish a ruby business more
quickly than I expected to and one of
the things that happen when Dave
introduced me to Ruby was I'm a dyslexic
and that means that I don't process
words the same way that you do the a lot
of the symbols are noise to me and and
they need to get out of the way and Ruby
had this wonderful freeing capability
for me to kind of disappear into the
background where I could focus on the
programming problem and the funny thing
about this book was that a lot of
American companies were having the same
kinds of problems they were they were
getting lost in all the abstractions and
all of the the ceremony of Java and we
weren't solving complicated problems at
the time we were taking a big fat
relational database and we were
babysitting that with a web-based user
interface and we were writing that same
application over and over and over and
you didn't need that big fat application
stack to do it
so funny thing about this book is that
in the United States it wasn't that
popular because by the time the book was
out everybody said hey we're ready for
this thing called Ruby but in Japan the
same thing wasn't true and the book was
was really important to people in a way
that I never really understood and so I
was invited to meet one of my one of my
idols this is the creator of Ruby Matz
and I love this picture I was just
looking for a picture of him and I like
this one because I bet he's been asked
that question thousands of times why do
people love Ruby and he says I guess
people love Ruby because you know
whatever
but when I spent time with Mets I'm
during that trip to Japan he you did he
used this piece this calmness this this
inner peace and joy that is difficult to
describe and the funny thing about it
was the community around ruby kind of
took those took those ideas to heart and
they started to take on Matz's
personality so much so that there was
this acronym if you guys heard this
before menace wand right Matz is nice
and so we are nice it's wonderful
wonderful men so I was at this
conference and I'll probably get some
details of this story wrong but I'll go
ahead and tell it anyway so this was the
first time that I'd ever speak into more
than a couple of hundred people there
were maybe somewhere between 500 and
1,000 people at this Ruby Ruby World
Conference and most of them did not
speak English so they were [ __ ] native
Japanese speakers and so I had to deal
with the translator the first time in my
life and like every young arrogant
speaker I said well I'm gonna break all
the rules and I'm gonna tell a bunch of
jokes right
so I said I'm gonna tell I told the
translator I'm gonna tell these four
jokes and when I tell these four jokes
you're going to you're going to
translate them but if nobody laughs the
first joke I'm gonna skip the rest of
them right so I told the first joke and
I was really nervous and everybody
laughed and then so I said okay yeah I
got into it and I told the second joke
and everybody laughed and then by the
time they got to the third one this
audience was rocking you're not thinking
I am the greatest speaker of all time
and I got to that fourth joke and I said
man I own this crowd and then I sat down
and matches next to me and he's looking
down and typing and he has a little bit
of a little bit of a grin and a snicker
and then I asked him what the translator
said and he started working on an email
and turning away from me a little
which is very much unlike him and I said
Matz how did they translate that joke
and he finally turned around he said mr.
Tate told a very funny joke you will
laugh now so that was a great moment
right it's that whole audience was
joyful because I was joyful and they
were feeding on that I was the joy I was
the joke but this is very very mess
right this very much caught the spirit
of the Ruby of the Ruby language that I
remembered that that people will felt
joy coating it because the language
would get out of the way this is an
example of a ruby program and you can
see that it reached kind of like English
it had this this great way of morphing
around the business problem that you
were trying to solve in this case
building web endpoints so it also had
this glorious and terrible capability of
letting you open any class at every time
at any time and changing fundamental
semantics that were going on inside
really useful and a really terrible idea
right called monkey-patching but I love
drew be beautiful syntax very low
friction and I love the idea that I can
get started really quickly and there
weren't many compilers and so at this
point I was working at a company called
I can make it better and I was starting
to get rolling with Ruby this was like
my fourth or fifth application that I
built with Ruby as the head guy that I
built up from scratch and I'd learned
some of the tricks went to cache and
when not to cache by the way the correct
rule it's never right caching is a deal
with the devil always but but yeah so I
was using I was using Ruby and I was
starting to second-guess this idea right
because compilers are there for a reason
and so what I can make it better I
started looking for a way out right I
started actually looking for ways to to
rewrite the application so out of my
fear I started researching what the next
programming paradigm was going to be and
what the next language in the
programming paradigm was going to be I
started writing seven languages out in
seven weeks out of fear and then we
eventually published the book just to
invite others to go along on the journey
with me and I never thought that it
would resonate with anyone I never
expected it to sell at all much less to
be famous for it I mean some of the code
if you've read it some of the code in
this book is terrible and I'll tell you
it wasn't it wasn't as bad after we
published it as it was when we first
wrote it but the guy who wrote the
foreword for this book is Joe Armstrong
great picture of Joe he passed us last
year and I really miss him it was a good
friend
I remember being in Stockholm and what
are their about hundred people in this
room maybe a few more so picture
cafeteria about this size picture me
sitting like maybe in the middle here a
middle front and Joe sitting in the
middle back and me having like the
casual conversation not with Joe he's
way across the room right in me making a
comment about Erlang syntax and then
somebody Joe standing up in the middle
of the room they're saying what do you
mean Erlang has a beautiful syntax yeah
so he had this joy about him well we
were coming from vastly different places
right because Joe was used to used to
something else I was used to this Ruby
thing and this is the thing that Joe
said was beautiful
but he was coming from a different place
right he was coming from prologue I said
hmm that makes a little bit more sense
now that I know that and he had this he
had this crazy way of bringing everybody
around bringing joy into everybody
around his joy of programming languages
his joy of crazy ideas I remember one
year the second year that I've been
invited to EUC the Erlang user community
in Stockholm I remember Joe saying Bruce
I think I'm gonna learn the jazz piano I
said what you know just this crazy
preposterous idea right and so so he had
this new huge piano in the middle of
this tiny room right and you know he
could barely play chopsticks on it and
the next year I came and he was playing
a jazz piano you know not great but not
horrible either and there was there were
like dozens of people standing around
listening to him Joe it was crazy
so the way that I met Joe was when I
actually wrote seven languages in seven
weeks Joe Joe was the first person that
I asked to review a chapter now I didn't
intend to I said I've got this erlang
chapter I don't know anything about
hurling I've only been riding it for for
three weeks and then my my editor says
why don't you send it to Joe and I was
just terrified right so I said look okay
so I sent him this I emailed it to him
and I get this I hear this this
enthusiastic email come back and he says
oh you mind throwing in the prologue
chapter as well and I said great that's
two languages I know nothing about right
and I'm giving it to the creator of the
language and I didn't hear anything for
a while and then then I got this tenor
dip No
from my editor saying I need to talk to
you right because Joe its senator
manager that's saying I get the sense
that this author understands Erlang very
well not true not true right but I don't
get the same sense for prologue this
prologue chapter is in trouble so I said
what the heck and I just I put my pride
to the side and I just called Joe
Armstrong and we worked and worked and
worked and and he was you know I picture
him laughing and smiling the whole time
is he's teaching me prologue and and
sharing his joy and this is some of what
was in seven languages in seven weeks
so prologue is full of facts like you
might have these little facts that says
Velveeta is a cheese rich is a cracker
spam is the type of meat and then
there's some flavors like sodas are
sweet desserts are sweet and then there
are these inferences so there's a if a
food flavor if there's a food flavor X&Y
that implies that food type of X is e
and flavor of Y is e and so you can make
inferences like that and then you could
ask Prolog to ask these questions hey
what what types of food or meats in
Prolog runs through the possibilities
and reply as spam and sausage and then
you could even ask about inferences and
say hey Prolog what foods are savory and
Prolog will run through those one
through those and match and run through
the iterations and find the things that
make it true and say okay yes
Velveeta spam and sausage or savory but
then we got to this this problem that
Joe suggested I had a pretty ugly
problem but Joe suggested replacing it
with the map coloring problem and he was
very patient with me he probably taught
this exercise I don't know maybe a
couple hundred times and he probably at
least run this type of program himself
that many more times
but over time I came up with a solution
and it was just jaw-droppingly simple
these colors are different from
themselves there's a coloring of Alabama
Mississippi Georgia Tennessee and
Florida such that and then you just list
you just say the colorings of the
individual states have to be different
in Prolog if you ask it what's the
coloring it comes up with the answer and
when I made this run Joe was laughing
laughing because he was sharing his joy
of Prolog because someone else was
calling what Joe called a Prolog moment
and I really miss him but that wasn't
the only language in seven languages in
seven weeks
I've since gotten to know a man named
John Hughes one of the creators of
Haskell and just recently I got to spend
some time with him as he as he came to
Chattanooga to host a conference that we
ran and he answered this question that
somebody asked about about how he finds
Erlang Erlang in Haskell which had very
different philosophies and I love the
way that that he expresses his ideas
here so I'm very much a fanatic of
Technology I love it very much I love it
and very much enjoy seeing that it's
finally bearing fruits see John loves
taking problems and formalizing them and
generalizing them so that he can
automate them you know quick check is a
marvelous invention so I was working
with with Ruby at the time and I was
finding problems like this popping up in
my code base because we didn't have
compiler errors right because like if
you take a you think the first element
of a list that might be nil and then you
take the ID if the nil
and that throws a nullpointerexception
and I was starting to hit a wall with
Ruby and it turns out that somebody else
was reading seven languages in seven
weeks that was a guy Abra a Brazilian
man currently living in Poland names
Jose Evelyn he's actually the creator of
the elixir language and so I jumped on a
plane jumped across the pond in stalked
Jose a to to London where we worked in a
conference together and we we shared a
lot of moments and and I decided that I
loved elixir and and we started working
together on on getting this language
adopted and so over time I got to
appreciate that the thing that loved
that josei loved about elixir was that
it was explicit especially the
complicated parts no it was very much
unlike my experience that I can make it
better so this was one of the most
joyous times in my career we were
actually I mean think about think about
the audacity of saying I need something
that's not Ruby I need a language that
that I really feel and then launching a
language to help make your startup
succeed that's basically what we did
with with a lick sir you know I won't
say that I was in the middle of the the
development of elixir but we we
definitely bet on it really hard and
really early but after a while I can
make it better got acquired and those
joyful moments started coming much more
slowly and I found myself in a bit of a
crisis
there's something that you need to know
about me about seven years before I
missed an insurance payment and I was
training for a marathon at the time and
you know I would run 16 miles
I just runs 16 miles I was was told that
that I needed to get a test an EKG test
too so that I could be insured again and
when I had that test taken they said you
need to go to the doctor now so I did
and I found myself laying in a garni
like this in the hallway like this and
being wheeled into surgery not a major
surgery a very minor one with the
incision would be a couple of
millimeters but it seems I had a problem
actually two problems in this left
anterior descending the lad artery which
is called the Widowmaker that didn't
sound like a good name to me so I woke
up in the middle of this surgical
procedure and everybody was surprised
that I woke up but to the doctor's
credit I mean I didn't feel any pain or
anything they had local anesthetic and
stuff so to the doctors credit he would
cover quickly and started talking me
through what he was doing and so he
squeezed this bulb and the bulb injected
this dye and you could see everything
get dark like it is in this chart and
you could see this thing that's supposed
to be straight turn into an hourglass so
that was the blockage and then they put
this metal tube in the skinny one is
before they expand it then they put a
balloon in it pop it out and then that
expands and and makes opens up the
passage so that I've never had any
symptoms since but being a heart patient
we have to pay attention to things like
stress so I'm in this crisis moment I've
lost my joy I was really thinking about
my more
tality because I knew that there's a
tight relationship between heart attacks
and stress I mean there's no denying
that right and I'm in the midst of one
of the most stressful jobs that there is
right so zooming in on this chart you'll
we're a third from the bottom which is
the worst place to be and you might say
that this is an American problem but
it's not an American problem it's a
rural problem and I think that sometimes
we let our joy or we let our stress
spill out onto others
my connection with Guido was that was
also a connection to books he actually
signed a book from one of my mentees a
man named Michael dosa who was bullied
as a kid african-american gentleman
Guido was very kind
he signed a Python book and dropped it
in the mail straight to my friend
Michael dosa and this this kind
brilliant man has stepped down because I
believe that so many so much of our
stress is spilling over onto the
creators of the things that we love so I
didn't like what I was becoming so I
packed up my family and we moved to
Tennessee and we did the thing that you
do when you want to reduce the stress in
your life we started a business I don't
know if it's a good idea yet I like the
logo though you like the logo there's a
word rock right to understand I get it
i grok it he Grox it that IO is really
ones and zeros so crocks ones and zeros
understands computers computer languages
that's what we were about so we started
thinking about what makes an elite
developer and we built a product and way
before we were ready in that products we
put it in front of my mentees and it
just didn't work not like we wanted it
to not without intervention so we
started asking a lot of programmers
questions and we got answers back that
we didn't expect
it wasn't the lessons that made them
smarter so we went back to the drawing
board we found this this study done at
use University of California at Davis
they they did this this seemingly wild
study they wired people up so that you
could see the activity in their brain
and they said hey I mean can you imagine
having having all this brain stuff all
over you and somebody asking hey what
Beatles single lasted the longest on the
charts I wouldn't be thinking about
anything right now but it turns out that
they did they got curious and when they
did centers of their brain lit up and
they were the same the same brain
centers that sparked dopamine let me say
that another way that curiosity sparks
joy and this was really cool to me
hey the answer learn more learn stuff
that makes you curious right but then
there's inevitably the problem of that
manager that says hey but if you're
taking less time to do the same work
isn't that work gonna be less so that's
a problem
so we said let's sit on that for a
little bit then we started talking to
more people we talked to this place
called the Chattanooga stem school
science technology and math and we ran
across this this school that had this
great computer science success and I
asked the teacher
what's your curriculum because I wanted
to you know steal his ideas and sell
them right and he said nothing we don't
have a curriculum what we do is we plant
we plant a need we plant a bug we give
them a problem that is so intensely
interesting and curious that they have
to go learn to code to solve it
incredible turns out there's some
science behind this so joy sparks
motivation and there's more science that
says joy store Sparks productivity this
shouldn't be that interesting or that
new to us but it kind of made a light
bulb turn on for me said that when
people say hey I'm going to take less
time to do work so that I could study
the stuff that makes me really curious
right and then I'm going to I'm going to
push on that stuff and I'm going to turn
on different receptors in my brain and
when I do I'm going to be a much better
developer so that I can do more work and
eventually that'll turn into a surplus
set another way that learning in this
way is sustainable so that's where we're
going
we're basically moving towards being a
tour guide for programming languages you
know partially to kind of jump off jump
off the things that were causing me so
much stress and do the things that I
love more like writing like video like
interacting with users talking to people
like you but partially because it's the
right thing to do let's say that you
want to build a ship this is one of
these quotes that floats around the
internet and doesn't have clean
attribution but it rings true to me so
I'm going to read it anyway if you wish
to build a ship don't divide the men
into teams and send them into the forest
to cut wood instead teach them to long
for the vast in endless sea
so you want to write better Java learn
somepony this so sylvan has very much
the opposite approach that mets did and
that's really interesting to me it isn't
about getting out of the way it's about
enforcing things and actually building
guarantees into the compiler so that we
can have we can have message passing
that's copy free and even with some
mutability in it but it's coated in such
a way in the type system is in such a
way that if it isn't correct it won't
compile said another way that the thing
that gives Sylvan joy is compilers so I
have a challenge to you to make some
time right and I'm not saying steal some
time from your families that's the
opposite of what I'm saying what I'm
saying is do the hard work of thinking
about your business day about thinking
about your business processes because
many of the leaders that are that are
going to be creating companies are in
this room right so make time to discover
the things that make you curious the
things that you'd like the things that
you don't like and I want to close
things out with an emotional moment that
I had in preparing for this talk so I
was looking for some quotes about the
importance of learning programming
languages and I ran into a quote that I
didn't recognize at the time and I want
to read it for you now
a Zen master might tell you that to be
better at mathematics you better study
Latin that's the dis with programming to
better understand the essence of
object-oriented programming you should
study logic or functional programming to
be better at functional programming you
should study assembler today not only
can we read about the ideas but we can
try them in practice this makes the
difference between standing on the pool
side wondering whether it will be nice
to swim and diving in and enjoying the
water what's cool is that this quote was
by Joe Armstrong and it was the foreword
for seven languages in seven weeks the
joy is in the journey
[Applause]
you
[Applause]